playing Star Wars growing up there was
always that one kid who would refuse to
play unless he could be darkside am I
looking at three of those kids right now
yes yes hmm
pretty much yeah yeah what makes this so
much what why we've all ended up on all
the ghosts gonna save like D is this was
this though what is it about being bad
in this universe that just makes it so
cool it's with a bit is it allows you to
really go to areas that you wouldn't be
able to go to and in in contemporary
drama sure certainly not in everyday
life that the extremes in these films
are are intense and you it allows you to
really go to the furthest reaches of
what it is to be able do you ever pull
it the snoke voice when just regular
life somebody calls the house you don't
want them to all the time good for you
and yeah I particularly like it when
they get cold called about you know some
assurance saying whatever yeah just kind
of go your I imagine your life between
with the amount of secrets that you have
to keep between this movie and Game of
Thrones dude you is it therapy that
helps you out is that when you lie in
bed at night is he are you a mess how do
you get through a day with the amount of
secrets that you are tasked to keep to
be honest I'm just quite happy not to
have to talk about myself it works for
me really yeah yeah everybody everybody
has somebody in their family who is
desperate for spoilers yeah right
everybody has that one cousin and uncle
whatever who was in your family who's in
your family that hounds you for spoilers
of that of this of this movie
I can go quickly I got nobody no-nobody
I've got really cool I have my brother
is in huge star wars okay and but
actually it's been very good at not
because he doesn't he actually want is
one of those who just doesn't want to
know so you'll go so you know and then
you'll go well it's there